hey everyone this is cereth registered
nurse sorry n.com and in this video I'm
gonna demonstrate for you how to use a
metered dose inhaler with a spacer okay
so what is a metered dose inhaler it is
an inhaler that will deliver a set
amount of a medication into the lungs so
it's used by people who have respiratory
diseases like asthma COPD and those
medications generally given are like
bronchodilators like albuterol or
corticosteroids like fluticasone like
which is flovent and these medications
will help either dilate the lungs which
is a bronchodilator or corticosteroid
which will help suppress immune system
decrease that inflammation in the lungs
now when using a metered dose inhaler it
is best to use a spacer and why is that
well whenever you're using those open or
closed mouth techniques like I
demonstrated in the previous video those
take a lot of dexterity you have to be
able to press the inhaler button down
and inhale at the same time and if don't
do it correctly a lot of the medication
will end up in the mouth and instead of
the lungs but using the spacer helps
decrease that because it gives the
patient in a sense time to hit the
button and inhale and it helps permit a
lot of that medications especially that
corticosteroid from collecting in the
mouth which can in the end cause thrush
so always try to get one of these for
your patients so let me show you how to
actually use it so the first thing we
want to do course is perform hand
hygiene perform the patient's five rides
make sure you have the right patient the
right drug the right time the right
route and the right dose because you'll
be giving these in pups so check all
that information out and another thing
you want to remember is while you're
doing your check off is that you want to
make sure you know exactly which inhaler
to give win for instance say you're
giving a bronchodilator and a
corticosteroid so the patient has two
inhalers which one would you want to get
first you want to give the
bronchodilator first because it's going
to dilate out that those lungs and then
five minutes later you would want to
you're corticosteroid so it can go in
there and do its job and decrease
inflammation also say that you were just
going to be giving one inhaler but it
required two puffs
well you would give the one dose that
they need the one puff and then one
minute later you can administer the
second puff so if you're giving the same
drug you would wait a minute but if
you're going to do bronchodilator and
then a corticosteroid you would want to
wait five minutes in addition after
giving the corticosteroid inhaler you
would want the patient to immediately
gargle and rinse with water and spit
that water out to remove any possible
corticosteroids that have collected in
the mouth because if they stay in the
mouth they can irritate those mucous
membranes and cause thrush so first of
all you want to do is you want to prime
the inhaler and you'll do that if this
is the first time you're using the
inhaler or if it's been dropped or the
patient hasn't used it in a week or more
if it's been recently cleaned and while
you're in the process of doing that just
check the inhaler make sure it's not
expired you can do that by popping it
off the canister and looking at the date
and this expires in 2020 so we're good
also just quickly check to make sure
there's enough doses in this inhaler and
of course if it's new there is enough
doses but this has been used before you
just want to make sure that you have
enough puffs in here and a lot of times
then hailer has a counter on it that you
can look at it or the box will tell you
how many doses are in each inhaler so
check that out in this particular one
there's two hundred sprays so you'll
want to count out how many times the
patient's going to be using it and how
many days that's going to transpire over
for instance if the patient was going to
be using this inhaler four times a day
twice in the morning twice at night
that's four puffs and it has 200 puffs
how many days is that gonna last us 50
days so you want to keep track of that
so to prime it what we're gonna do is
we're going to take the cap off and just
check inside the inhaler make sure
there's nothing hanging out in there
sometimes patients like to keep these in
their purse and some
and other things can get in there and
you don't want them to inhale it so make
sure it's clean and we're going to give
it a good shake so hold it in between
your thumb and your fingers and shake it
for about eight to ten seconds get it
mixed up really well and then we're
gonna give it four sprays so it's nice
and primed so after priming inhaler
you're ready to connect and hailer to
the spacer so make sure that the cap of
the inhaler is off and then take the cap
of the spacer off because this is the
mouthpiece where the patient's going to
put their mouth at and actually inhale
and then this part right here is where
you're going to connect the mouthpiece
of inhaler into the spacer so just
connect it like so and it stays on then
have your patient set up hold the
inhaler with the thumb and with the
fingers and then just give it a good
shake for eight to ten seconds then have
a patient breathe in through the mouth
and then out through the mouth until
they can no longer breathe out
they will seal their mouth around this
chamber with in between their teeth or
tongue flat and then they will press the
inhaler down and then inhale so it's
different from those other techniques
that we use where they had to
simultaneously press it down and inhale
so they press it down then inhale inhale
until they can no longer inhale anymore
and then they'll hold it for about 10 to
12 seconds and then breathe out slowly
and again they would want to rinse their
mouth if they use corticosteroids and if
they have to repeat the dose they will
do that in one minute so now let me show
you what that would look like
and after that of course you will have
the patient rinse their mouth gargle and
spit water if it was a corticosteroid
and you will recap your inhaler and your
spacer then perform hand hygiene and
document okay so that wraps up this
video on how to use a metered dose
inhaler with a spacer thank you so much
for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for more videos